the Conklin car mr. Sasha cannot reminds
us the competition in the luxury class
is very tough even major manufacturers
like Audi and BMW have a hard time up
against the leader of the fact the
Mercedes s-class and so it's hardly
surprising when some of them tinker with
their positioning for example Maserati
with the Quattro port or Porsche with
the Panamera and now that's what Jaguar
is doing with the XJ tilt while older
jaguars maintain the British tradition
of understatement
the new XJ is much sporty-er than its
predecessors Jaguar describes this model
as its most daring interpretation to
date the XJ came out with a facelift in
2016 this version offers LED headlights
and rear lights the power steering is
now electromechanical
[Music]
inside this big cat simply purrs with
luxury quilted leather seats are
reminiscent of Baroque design the
Meridian sound system with up to 1300
watts pampers passengers in the
portfolio variant a twelve point three
inch HD display serves as instrument
panel the eight inch display and the
middle console can operate by touch as
with modern smartphones it recognizes
the swipe
the trunk has 520 liters of storage
space men and Sasha says that the right
hand backseat may be the most
comfortable spot in the Mercedes s-class
but in the Jaguar XJ the driver's seat
is best leg room in the backseat is
adequate but the Headroom isn't so great
still there is plenty of comfort and
luxury with seat heating that can also
cool and for zone air conditioning as
well
tima automatic I invited come from
another comfort feature is the nonlinear
steering the wheels not only turn more
the more you turn the steering wheel the
rate at which they turn increases that's
especially convenient when you want to
park or shunt this feature may not
please everyone but Sasha likes it our
test car with the portfolio package
costs just under 93 thousand euros in
Germany Jaguar says combined fuel
consumption is 5.7 liters per 100
kilometers two engines are available
with the portfolio package this diesel
and a three liter gasoline engine
be fun and Sasha is testing the 3 liter
diesel it puts out 221 kilowatts or 300
horsepower and 700 Newton meters of
torque that's quite a bit
Sasha likes that the tried-and-true ZF
8-speed automatic transmission transmits
power to the rear axle almost silently
on the intox the vehicle isn't the
Jaguar XJ glides over the blacktop with
effortless elegance
[Music]
yes
Sasha says top-notch acoustic insulation
makes the cars comfort perfect even the
sound of the horn hardly reaches the
interior an app enables the owner to
carry out many functions via a
smartphone for example he receives an
immediate warning if the car is broken
into or stolen the car can also be
located with an app plus you can preheat
the interior or check your fuel gauge
with a smartphone all-wheel drive is
available only in combination with the
gasoline engine the diesel engine comes
only with rear-wheel drive a 5-liter v8
compressor comes in the XJR model which
costs about 50,000 euros more than the
xj version we're testing it produces 405
kilowatts
[Music]
sascha regrets that his luxurious drive
must come to an end when parking
remember that the Jaguar XJ is a large
car and visibility around it isn't as
good as might be desired
but that's why it comes with a
360-degree panoramic camera if you rely
on the rear view mirror remember that
the rear window is extremely sloped
which means you can't really see the
rear end of the car from inside but
Sasha says he had a lot of fun driving
the Jaguar XJ with a three liter diesel
engine and that the driver's seat is
definitely the best place in this sedan